en
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre dans un
instant les questions cribles consacré
au logement étudiant
trouver un logement et bien c'est très
souvent le parcours du combattant pour
de très nombreux étudiants
le nombre de places en cité
universitaire est en effet très limité
en france seulement 7% des étudiants
parviennent à être logés dans l'une des
160 5000 places que comportent les
résidences universitaires françaises la
faute notamment et bien aux politiques
publiques qui pendant très longtemps on
ignorait ce problème le logement
étudiant fait également l'objet de très
grandes disparités alors évidemment dans
la capitale apparaît mais aussi dans de
très nombreuses autres villes comme par
exemple toulouse ou nice
on sait que là-bas et bien la situation
est très tendue
résultat est bien de très nombreux
étudiants sont logés dans le parc privé
d'autant plus que l'on sait que
l'attribution des résidences étudiantes
reste pour l'instant très opaque
c'est donc le sujet dont les sénateurs
vont se saisir cet après midi ils vont
poser leurs questions au crible au
secrétaire d'état chargée des sports
thierry braillard
c'est lui qui va répondre à leurs
questions alors je vous rappelle le
principe des questions cribles les
sénateurs disposent de deux minutes pour
poser la question puis le ministre peut
répondre lui en deux minutes et enfin
deux minutes pour la réplique tout de
suite donc on va prendre la direction de
l'hémicycle qui est présidé cette après
midi par la vice-présidente du sénat
jacqueline gourault est un sujet de
préoccupation majeur pour l'ensemble des
français
les causes de ces inquiétudes sont
parfaitement connus le manque dramatique
de constructions nouvelles et la hausse
constante des loyers
ces craintes sont encore amplifiées
lorsqu'il s'agit des plus jeunes et a
fortiori des étudiants selon les
dernières études le taux d'effort
nécessaires concernant le logement est
d'environ 22% chez les jeunes de moins
de 25 ans
et avoisine les 53 % chez les étudiants
une enquête de l'unef révèlent de plus
que le prix des loyers des petites
surfaces dans le privé a augmenté de 3,1
pour cent pour cette dernière rentrée
universitaire ces difficultés
financières s'ajoutent à la pénurie
grandissante de logements étudiants
à titre d'exemple en région parisienne
seuls 3 % des étudiants sont logés en
cité universitaire les réponses
apportées comme la caution locative
étudiante la clé vont dans le bon sens
et je les salue
mais elles sont largement insuffisantes
et ne traite pas la source du problème à
savoir la question de l'offre de
logement le plan 40000 lancé au début de
cette année fixe des objectifs ambitieux
et nécessaire mais je crains qu'il ne
puisse être réalisée par manque de
financement et de réserves budgétaires
alors monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous nous dire où vous en êtes
avec la construction de logements
étudiants
avec quels moyens précis pouvez-vous
favoriser leur construction est ainsi
remédier à la difficulté constante et
croissante pour nos étudiants
une autre mesure pour développer l'offre
serait de prendre en compte les besoins
des étudiants dans le projet
d'aménagement et de développement
durable le pea d'aidé qui est un
document du pmu quelle est votre opinion
sur cette proposition
je vous remercie de votre réponse
monsieur très ribard ailleurs vous avez
la parole
madame la présidente madame messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur comme
vous avez raison de signaler que le
logement étudiant doit être une priorité
j'avais dire ça fait des années qu'on
entend que ce soit une priorité
il n'a pas échappé qu'avec le plan 40000
à partir de 2013 l'état en faisait une
priorité
maintenant par rapport aux
interrogations qui sont les vôtres
quel est le bilan que l'on peut tirer de
cette opération logement 40 milles
car on est bien d'accord là dessus ça
nous rassemble au delà des effets
d'annoncé il y à la réalité concrète
que peuvent voir et connaître les
étudiants concernant le bilan huit mille
500 nouvelles places ont été créées en
2013 au sein des crous dont 3900
construction et 4600 réhabilitation en
bien qu'il soit trop tôt où on mange
parle pour tirer un bilan définitif 8130
places devraient être livrés dont deux
mille deux cent quarante et une
construction et 4071 réhabilitation ces
données et c'est important ne prennent
en compte que le nombre de places crous
ou en gestion crous les logements
construits par les organismes de hlm est
gérée en régie ou par des associations
ainsi que les logements conventionnés à
loyer plafonné créé par les opérateurs
privés ne sont pas totalement consolider
et pas pris en compte dans les chiffres
que je viens de vous donner c'est
justement l'une des missions de la
nouvelle mission qui vient d'être
confiée à monsieur prévost c'est à dire
qu'en complément la titre d'information
nous pouvons cependant indiqué que 7661
logements étudiants ont été financés en
2013 pour 2014
ce nombre s'élève s'élevait à l'été à
1938 mais devait devrait augmenter
notamment sur ces derniers mois
cependant et pour conclure malgré ces
chiffres positifs
il convient de rester où ils avaient
raison extrêmement vigilants sur la
banque conduite des opérations de
logements et en particulier de logement
social y compris étudiants en effet
certains projets se retrouvent bloqués
ceci n'est pas acceptable et où le
premier ministre lui-même aidé
intervenue il ya quelques jours là
dessus car il conviendra plique chacun a
sa responsabilité pour que les projets
de logements ne soient pas retardés dans
le contexte de crise du logement et de
construction que nous connaissons la
construction de logements étudiants est
une priorité de l'action du gouvernement
le logement ne doit pas être un obstacle
à la poursuite d'études et à la réussite
étudiante et concernant son financement
il faut aussi exploré toutes les voies
et notamment celles qui peuvent aller
sur le développement durable
merci monsieur le ministre pour la
réplique la parole est à claude kern
pour une minute
j'ai noté les efforts qui sont faits
vous avez pris également note de la
proposition d'inscription dans le pead
était mais si vous le permettez monsieur
le ministre je voudrais quand même
exprimé un regret et sans vouloir mettre
en cause vos compétences
loin de moi cette idée je trouve quand
même dommage que madame la ministre en
charge de ce dossier n'ait pas pris la
peine de se déplacer
vu l'importance du sujet la parole est à
monsieur jacques grosperrin pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
porte sur la caution locative étudiante
le logement est le premier poste de
dépense 48 % du budget au niveau
national et 50% ça quand ça % en
ile-de-france selon l'observatoire de la
vie étudiante 1,1 million d'étudiants
sont locataires du parc privé mais 16%
d'entre c'est-à-dire 180 mille étudiants
ont du mal à fournir une garantie et à
régler la caution demandée par le
bailleur la création d'un dispositif de
cautionnement par l'état vise donc ces
étudiants qui sont souvent issus de
familles modestes
après la période test de 2013 la clé a
été élargie dans toutes les académies au
mois d'août alors que ce dispositif
concerné moins deux des mille
bénéficiaires tous les étudiants de
moins de 28 ans pourront bénéficier dès
lors de la caution états à condition que
leur loyer soit inférieur à 500 euros
dans les régions à moins de 6 ans en ile
de france à moins de 700 à paris
en cas de non paiement du loyer l'état
paiera le bailleur pour une durée de six
mois
je voudrais faire plusieurs observations
la première je regrette hésitations de
la loi lure et le caractère tardif de la
réforme qui a permis à la plupart des
étudiants de cette rentrée universitaire
de ne pas bénéficier justement de cette
aide
je m'interroge finalement sur le fonds
de garantie qui interviendra en cas
d'impayés il est prévu bien sûr que
plusieurs acteurs alimenteront l'état le
cnous la caisse des dépôts des
cotisations à hauteur de 600 mille euros
les régions partenaires à hauteur de
cent mille euros et les étudiants
concernés versant de leur part une
cotisation de 5 % du montant du loyer
si le dispositif rencontrer
compte la faveur des étudiants car nous
serons souvent dans une situation
difficile je souhaiterais connaître
monsieur le ministre ces conditions de
montée en charge
je m'interroge également sur la capacité
de l'état recouvrer les séances
contractées par les mauvais payeurs
ce qui risquerait de déséquilibrer les
comptes enfin je m'étonne de
plafonnement des loyers exigés par ce
dispositif ministre vous avez la parole
madame la présidente madame messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
grosperrin dans un premier temps
permettez moi quand même de m'étonner de
votre étonnement je pense que on aurait
pu entendre dans vos propos le fait que
vous pouviez dire bravo au gouvernement
car au moins voilà quelque chose qui
pouvait nous réunir et sur lequel vous
pouviez être satisfaits de ce qui a été
fait car il faut savoir que le seul
dispositif qui existait auparavant
c'était le loca-pass pour les étudiants
uniquement boursiers salariés que la
grâce à la caution locative étudiante on
généralise un système et que si tous les
étudiants on dit bravo
j'aurais espéré mais l'espoir fait vivre
qu au niveau du sénat même sur cette
mesure on puisse avoir unanimité sur son
fonctionnement donc vous me questionné
pour savoir si tout cela bien et
organiser oui cela a bien été organisé
il ya une expérimentation donc dans
plusieurs régions vous l'avez dit
maintenant le dispositif depuis la
rentrée 2014 et donc généralisée et pour
l'ensemble des étudiants
il ya un fonds de garantie qui fait qu'
on a sur la pérennisation de tout de
tout paiement l'état abonder ce fonds de
garantie la caisse des dépôts la des
dépôts et consignations la bande est
aussi il ya la participation des régions
qui souhaitent s'associer à ce
dispositif et des cotisations versées
par les étudiants donc c'est un
dispositif qui aujourd'hui fonctionne on
a énormément de demandes et c'est très
bien car il faut savoir que quand on
sait que le logement peut être le poste
plus essentiel dans la vie d'un étudiant
il y avait beaucoup d'étudiants qu'il
n'arrivait pas à pouvoir louer
quelconque studio parce que il y avait
toujours ce problème de garantie et de
caution qui était demandée il suffisait
que les parents ne puisse pas pour plein
de raisons pouvoir y répondre
il y avait j'allais dire une
disqualification et l'étudiant ne
pouvait pas avoir le logement qu'il
souhaitait grâce à cette caution
cette hypothèque élevé et je crois qu'on
peut dire qu'aujourd'hui l'état se porte
garant
parfois ils avoir confiance en l'état je
pense que c'est pas au parlement qu on
va poser cette question que bien sûr
concernant la sagesse des sénateurs
vous savez que quand l'état s'engage il
garantit toujours ses engagements
la parole est à monsieur grosperrin
comme la présente je pourrais être
satisfait bien sûr mais vous proposer le
garantis dont les coûts pour les
finances publiques sont à certains en
limitant son utilisation dans le
contexte bien sûr d'une offre de toute
manière contrainte
cela me semble un petit peu hasardeuse
alors qu'il faudrait à lutter contre les
causes profondes des prix devenus
prohibitifs dans les grandes villes
merci merci la parole est au président
jacques mézard pour le groupe rdse
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
porte sur le logement étudiant dans les
antennes universitaires dit délocalisé
dans nos villes moyennes
car dans ces villes dans ces
agglomérations moyennes se sont le plus
souvent les conseils généraux les
agglomérations les communes qui
concourent largement au financement de
ces antennes pour les locaux
d'enseignement pour la restauration pour
le logement des étudiants
d'ailleurs souvent à la limite des
compétences facultatives voire de toute
compétence sans que l'état d'ailleurs
n'y trouva rien à redire et nous avons
très souvent les pires difficultés pour
faire intervenir les crous qui font tout
ce qu'ils peuvent pour ne pas intervenir
dans ces antennes délocalisées au moment
de la réforme territoriale
au moment de la création de très grandes
régions
je voudrais savoir monsieur le ministre
quelles sont les intentions du
gouvernement pour la clarification des
compétences dans ce domaine là est ce
que les grandes régions dont on nous dit
elles vont faire beaucoup pour nos
territoires ruraux enclavées lvs vont
elles se voir attribuer cette compétence
puisqu'elles sont censés par leur
puissance apporter à nos territoires
ruraux à nos antennes délocalisées les
moyens qui nous manque aujourd'hui
ministre vous avez la parole la
présidente madame messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur mézard si je vous
répondais directement votre question
vous seriez le premier à dire mais à
quoi sert le sénat
si monsieur le ministre vous ne l'êtes
déjà ce qui va sortir de la discussion
et négociation de la du fameux projet de
loi d'autres dont je sais en plus que
votre regard acéré sur ce texte vous
amènera par la voie d'amendement à dire
vous même ce que vous souhaitez faire en
matière de compétences des régions par
rapport à l'état par rapport au
département ou par rapport aux
communautés de communes il est clair
qu'à ce jour
qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit que les
régions participent au cofinancement en
matière de construction de logements
étudiants en lien avec les crous
principalement et que je ne vois pas
pourquoi cela
jayas changerait et j'allais même dire
au contraire je pense que plus les
régions seront importantes
plus les moyens dégagés par les
économies d'échelle le seront et je
pense que dans la future région
si bien sûr le sénat à l'adopter ainsi
meskina me semble avoir été le cas sur
sa carte
la fameuse région rhône alpes auvergne
fera que j'ai la certitude que dans
cette région on fracas de l'homogénéité
du territoire et que notamment la ville
d'aurillac ne sera pas complètement
oublié dans le cadre du plan 40 mille
d'ailleurs monsieur le sénateur je sais
qu'il ya des opéras deux opérations sont
menées sur aurillac d'extension une
extension qui est prévu de 40 places un
démarrage des travaux a commencé je
crois en mai dernier pour une mise en
service
rentrer après la rentrée 2015 concernant
l'iut de l'université d'auvergne à
l'école d'infirmières et puis vous avez
aussi une antenne 2 le s p a donc là
et c'est à vous à dire ce que vous le
souhaitez mais je ne pense pas qu'il est
prévu pour l'instant que la région ça
rog le pouvoir de concernant le logement
étudiant pour la réplique la parole est
au président mézard merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre vous
êtes un grand sportif
donc vous savez ce que c'est que botter
en touche et et vous venez de nos en
faire une démonstration magnifique
il n'en reste pas moins que le texte sur
la fusion de régions c'est un projet du
gouvernement que le son de le second
texte sur les compétences c'est un
projet du gouvernement est que je n'ai
pas eu l'impression jusqu'ici que le
gouvernement ait beaucoup l'intention de
changer ses objectifs en la matière or
il est important pour nos territoires
ruraux de savoir si le gouvernement
entend qu'il y ait une véritable
clarification sur ces questions
d'enseignement supérieur car nous avons
besoin par dessus tout dans nos
territoires ruraux de matière grise
monsieur le ministre et que les efforts
considérables que nous menons pour
maintenir et développer de la matière
grise
nous sommes à bout financièrement et
qu'il est indispensable que le
gouvernement nous dise s'il entend nous
aider dans cet objectif là ou pas et
jusqu'ici je dois dire que je n'ai pas
eu de véritable réponse merci la parole
est à monsieur joël labbé pour le groupe
écologiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues au fil des
années on assiste à une dégradation des
conditions de vie des étudiants
comme l'ont rappelé vos deux collègues
ministres chargés l'une de
l'enseignement et l'autre de la
recherche
le système ne fait pas que reproduire
les inégalités il les aggrave
le parc privé loge une grande majorité
des étudiants
trois cent quarante mille logements
réservés aux étudiants pour un total de
deux millions et demi d'étudiants le
nombre d'étudiants est en augmentation
de 2
pour cent par an c'est mieux que notre
taux de croissance en france on a plus
de croissance on a plus de croissance
mais on a encore de plus en plus
d'étudiants et c'est là une véritable
richesse
un tiers des étudiants vivent chez leurs
parents
ceux qui ont la chance d'avoir cette
proximité de famille un tiers loue un
logement privé seuls ou en couple et le
dernier tiers se partage entre la
colocation et les trop rares places en
logements réservés aux étudiants trop
peu d'étudiants bénéficient de bourses
et nombreux sont ceux qui doivent
travailler pour vivre en menant leurs
études dans un contexte de chômage
galopant
avouez que cela relève d'un comble
étudié pour éviter le chômage et devoir
travailler pour étudier les aides au
logement les apl notamment ont eu depuis
leur mise en place un effet pervers
celui de faire augmenter les loyers
c'est là un phénomène économique bien
connu il faudra instaurer un
plafonnement des loyers afin de remédier
à cette situation les plus touchées sont
là encore les étudiants car il change
souvent de logements permettant ainsi
aux propriétaires de revers valoriser le
loyer quasiment à chaque rentrée
universitaire aucune autre hymne
inégalités par dont les loyers les plus
élevés au mètre carré sont ceux des plus
petites surfaces donc celles
privilégiées par les étudiants faute de
moyens dans ce contexte monsieur le
ministre
pouvez vous nous donner un calendrier de
la mise en place de l'encadrement des
loyers tel qu'il a été voté par le
parlement
cette mesure est essentielle notamment
pour les plus petits logements mash up
majoritairement occupés par les
étudiants est seule à même actuellement
dans notre contexte budgétaire de leur
donner une bonne bouffée d'air pur fine
bouffée d'air une bouffée d'air pur
car ils en ont grand besoin merci
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
messieurs c'est un temps la baie tout
d'abord parce que je n'ai pas fait lors
de ma première réponse vous
m'autoriserai à excuser
geneviève forest fioraso qui est en
déplacement en argentine et qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas être présente aujourd'hui
est donc c'est pour cela que je le
plaisir de la remplacer sur un sujet où
de façon générale dans le début de vos
propos faut-il rappeler que le
gouvernement qui a des projets de loi
mais qui a aussi déjà fait voter des
textes qui a mis en place un plan
concernant la vie étudiante et le
logement étudiant qui est le sujet qui
nous rassemblent aujourd'hui je rappelle
quand même le plan 40000 où j'ai répondu
tout à l'heure à votre question je
rappelle la mise en place de la caution
locative étudiante pour l'ensemble des
étudiants
je rappelle aussi et ça nous a pas
échappé qu'il y à 135 mille nouveaux
boursiers à cette rentrée et que ce
n'est pas l'opération du hasard c'est
des choix budgétaires assumé qui fait
qu'on augmente le nombre de boursiers
vous savez que ça a été la petite
polémique concernant les bourses au
mérite mais il valait mieux de mon point
de vue avoir cédé plus de boursiers
135000 c'est 458 millions d'euros
supplémentaires sur cette ligne
budgétaire
c'est un choix politique que nous
assumons alors derrière vous poser après
une question plus précise concernant
l'encadrement des loyers et la loi
allure qui a été voté par le parlement
en avril 2014
il se trouve que vous le savez le
premier ministre l'a rappelé aux côtés
de madame pinel ministre du logement des
territoires et de la ruralité que cette
loi allure
concernant incongrûment des loyers
allait être mis en place de façon
pragmatique et non pas de façon
universelle et à partir d'une date
donnée c'est la raison pour laquelle
dans cette évolution
il y aura une expérimentation sur paris
à partir de 2015
et comme l'a dit le premier ministre
toutes les agglomérations qui le
souhaiteront pourront mettre en place
cette avance et pragmatique
je sais que l'agglomération lilloise a
commencé à émettre une volonté et
jailliront fera du cas par cas pour voir
comment cette expérimentation sera menée
en lien avec l'observatoire des loyers
car on peut pas mener cette politique
encadrement sans avoir les résultats de
l'observatoire des loyers
merci
ces mini sur l'ensemble du territoire je
termine mme la présidente on n'a pour
l'instant pas les données suffisantes
pour faire ça de façon de territoriales
monsieur l'abbé vous avez la parole
merci de cette réponse de monsieur le
ministre vous n'étiez pas accusés
s'étaient c'était un constat
effectivement des efforts sont faits
vous l'avait dit et on ne peut que les
reconnaître mais mais ils sont encore
insuffisants on se doit de s'en rendre
compte
lorsque vous parlez de la question de
l'encadrement des loyers effectivement
études complémentaires ne pas être admis
être pragmatique et pas dogmatique mais
cette question de l'encadrement des
loyers qui était une mesure majeure de
la loi allure il va falloir que
rapidement elle puisse être
véritablement opérationnel et notamment
pour le sujet qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui les logements et aux
étudiants je vous remercie
merci madame brigitte gonthier maurin
pour le groupe communiste républicain et
citoyen merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
à l'initiative de cette séance mon
groupe souhaite interpeller le
gouvernement sur la politique conduite
face à la pénurie de logements étudiants
je le ferai la lumière du cas de la
résidence universitaire d'antony là et
rua dans les hauts-de-seine la et rue à
et ses onze hectares comptait
initialement plus de 2000 logements soit
14 % du parc étudiants d'ile-de-france
après une longue bataille juridique un
accord que j'avais contesté aux côtés de
l'association de défense de la et rurale
de l'unef et des élus de gauche du
département a été signé en juin 2013 par
l'état le président du conseil général
des hauts-de-seine monsieur devedjian la
communauté d'agglomération duo bièvre et
anthony pour entériner le transfert à
titre gratuit de la et rue à la
communauté d'agglo cet accord est censée
maintenir 1080 logements sur site
un chiffre très en deçà des besoins il
prévoit aussi la création de 1200
logements nouveaux dans le périmètre de
la cab et des communes limitrophes ainsi
que la construction de 3000 logements à
l'échelle du département
cela sans plus de précisions en 2008
déjà par convention avec l'état
le conseil général du 92 s'était engagé
à produire 3000 logements étudiants en
cinq ans seuls 1300 ont été livrés et
avec des loyers plus cher le transfert
de la et rurales ne s'est traduit pour
le moment que par des destructions et
par l'inoccupation de deux bâtiments
seul un bâtiment a fait l'objet d'une
réhabilitation est tout juste entamée
d'ailleurs la cape de plus s'apprête à
faire des moves à démolir un bâtiment
supplémentaire donc quatre bâtiments
sont encore debout et pourrait être
réhabilité
pourquoi ne pas l'exiger je m'étonne
d'ailleurs que la ministre ait reporté
la réunion du comité de suivi quand de
nouvelles démolitions sont prévues avant
que les constructions promise elles ne
sortent de terre
le gouvernement doit exiger un chiffrage
transparent un calendrier précis de
construction à moi évidemment qu'il ne
cautionne
au final la fermeture définitive de la
heriot exerçant ainsi le souhait de
monsieur devait merci chers collègues
nous sommes venus vous avez la parole à
la présidente mais messieurs les
sénateurs même la sénatrice compte y est
morin tout d'abord je dois vous rappeler
que dans le plan 40000 19 1342 places
seront construites en ile de france
d'ici la fin 2010 est que ce soit par
rapport aux constructions de logements
via les crous ou en logements privés en
ce qui concerne l'avenir de résidence
d'antony qui porte un beau nom celle de
jean zay les c'est l'objet de la
convention comme vous l'avez rappelé qui
a été signé le 28 juin 2013
entre l'état les collectivités
territoriales avec des objectifs et je
tiens à les rappeler cette convention
lie en effet les programmes de
réhabilitation de démolition et de
construction afin de maintenir une
capacité d'accueil équivalente
il ya trois secteurs de réalisation de
logements pour août versailles pour un
total de 3700 80 logements en tout c'est
dans ce contexte qui est intervenue la
décision du conseil communautaire de
l'agglomération des hauts de bièvre le
de voter le 16 mai dernier une
délibération autorisant la démolition du
bâtiment g de la résidence jean zay
d'antony dont les travaux démolition
vient de débuter
l'êta demandé conformément aux
engagements pris lors du premier comité
de pilotage du 24 octobre 2013 que les
travaux de démolition ne soit pas
engagée avant le lancement de la
réhabilitation des 311 studio du
bâtiment a qui viennent donc de débuter
parallèlement l'état a décidé de
reporter la dernière réunion du comité
de pilotage vous niez de le dire afin
que les collectivités puissent présenter
un calendrier précis de la programmation
des opérations de réhabilitation de la
résidence jean zay et des constructions
permettant de respecter les engagements
qu'elles ont contractés dans le cadre de
la convention du 28 juin 2013
je dois vous dire ma cicatrice que
l'idée de ce report fait qu'on veut une
décision définitive avant la fin de
cette année se tient donc à vous
rassurer sur la détermination de l'état
qui sera dans ce dossier ni naïf ni
complaisant et on a demandé au recteur
de versailles au préfet des
hauts-de-seine de suivre avec la plus
grande attention la mise en oeuvre de ce
processus et des engagements pris merci
monsieur le ministre la réplique pour
madame conclut mora merci monsieur le
ministre pour ces précisions nous avons
besoin d'engagements fermes et exigent
de l'état sur ce sur ce dossier parce
que le crous d'île de france c'est quand
même un des crous les moins bien doté il
ya pourtant 630 mille étudiants en
ile-de-france et 26 % quand même du
total en france et c'est pour ça que le
cas de la heriot à anthony et si
déterminant au pour l'instant ce que
l'on voit ce sont des destructions 548
chambres 91 t2 qui ont été rasés alors
qu'il y à peine uhry et qu'il faudrait
au contraire être capable de faire
surgir des milliers des milliers et de
logements et en veillant d'ailleurs à un
haut niveau d niveau des loyers
parce que évidemment réhabiliter ne doit
pas engager un surcoût pour pour les
étudiants je regrette je regrette toute
cette évolution parce que la région qui
a la compétence logement comme chacun
sait avait prévu
budget de réhabilitation et un plan de
réhabilitation or semble-t-il ce plan
venait contrarier le plan d'autres
personnes dans le département
donc j'appelle vraiment à la vigilance
les quarante mille logements c'est bien
mais ça sera pas suffisant il ya une
telle pénurie
un tel mal logement et je rappelle que
évidemment accéder à un logement
étudiant social ses pouvoirs pour bien
dans bien grand qu'à accéder tout
simplement aller aux études à la
poursuite d'études pour les plus
défavorisés
c'est donc assez chers collègues nafti
la parole est à madame dominique gillot
pour le groupe socialiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'éducation nationale de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche ou à la
secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche que nous avait indiqué qu'elle
était en déplacement
je vous remercie donc monsieur le
ministre de bien vouloir répondre même
si un collègue a déjà abordé ce sujet
tout à l'heure il me semble que dans sur
certains sujets la répétition des
arguments n'est pas nuisible à la bonne
compréhension
alors que les étudiants doivent
consacrer jusqu'à 50 % de leur budget
pour se loger
agir sur l'habitat autonome de
l'étudiant sait utiliser le principal
levier pour alléger le poids financier
de ces études et améliorer durablement
la qualité de vie étudiante propice à la
réussite du plus grand nombre comme le
disait ma collègue il ya un instant un
faisceau de mesures multiples afin
d'agir sur ce poste de dépense d'un
étudiant est aujourd'hui déployée par le
gouvernement c'est tout d'abord le plan
des quarante mille logements oui
quarante mille nouveaux logements
sociaux pour les étudiants en cinq ans
il semble que les objectifs sont en
passe d'être atteint et c'est heureux
pour les jeunes de france hautement
favorable à la démocratisation et
l'accessibilité l'enseignement supérieur
un autre dispositif vise à faciliter
l'accès des étudiants un logement
autonome
effectivement en dehors du montant du
loyer et de la rareté du logement social
il existe un élément discriminant
socialement celui de la caution locative
assise ainsi à paris le coût moyen d'un
logement étudiant dans le parc locatif
privé s'élève à 630 3 euros
les propriétaires demandent que la
personne se portant caution
souvent les parents est une rémunération
au moins égale à 4 fois le montant du
loyer ce qui représente plus de 2500
euros
c'est insupportable pour beaucoup de
familles infranchissable pour beaucoup
de familles souvent impossible pour les
familles monoparentales
l'observateur de la vie étudiante relève
d'ailleurs que 16 % des étudiants loger
dans le privé ont les plus grandes
difficultés à trouver un garant c'est
donc pour l'étudiant qui n'a pas encore
eu la chance d'obtenir un logement
social
le parcours du combattant allant de sous
location en sous location
en réponse à cette situation et dans le
cas de la priorité jeunesse fixé par le
président de la république il a été
annoncé le 8 septembre dernier chez
recoller la généralisation à tout le
territoire métropolitain et ultramarin
de l'expérimentation menée l'an dernier
alors l'opérateur crous a été mobilisé
afin de déployer le dispositif était
évoqué un délai de réponse à l'étudiant
faisant une telle demande de 72 heures
geneviève fioraso réclamait un délai de
48 heures pour réduire les risques de
perte de chance et la concurrence sur un
même logement
alors j'aimerais monsieur le ministre
que vous ne fassiez connaître le bilan
de cette mesure
son impact social les délais de réponse
ainsi que le nombre de bénéficiaires et
les modalités de fiabilisation de cette
caution locative études féministes vous
avez la parole sénatrice
merci de reposer cette question que
c'est vrai que tout à l'heure on avait
un petit sentiment qu'ils pouvaient
laisser penser que cette mesure qui n'a
jamais été prises auparavant il a fallu
que ce gouvernement là prennent commence
à être questionné à être discuté alors
qu'elle a l'aval de l'intégralité des
étudiants qui vont pouvoir en bénéficier
il faut savoir le dire
et pour paraphraser votre question
gr c'est vrai que dans les enceintes
parlementaires on a parfois dans les
questions cribles souvent des questions
où on nous parle des trains qui arrivent
en retard
merci d'en poser une pour concernant les
trains qui arrivent à l'heure
donc concernant le bilan que vous me
demandiez si sa demande de caution
locative étudiantes avaient été déposées
en 2013 lors de la phase
d'expérimentation et il ya eu aucun cas
de défaillance qui a été relevé en 2013
ça me permet de faire une réponse
complémentaire et c'est intéressant de
le dire à la fin de septembre 2014
plus de 5000 demandes de clés de caution
locative étudiantes ont été déposés et
2658 ont d'ores et déjà été attribués ce
qui correspond à une montée en charge
satisfaisante
le traitement des dossiers par les crous
se fait en moyenne à 48 heures et donc
je crois que c'est important il faut
aussi pour les messieurs mes amis
sénateurs savoir que pour profiter de ce
dispositif le montant des loyers qui
sont couverts par l'état sont plafonnés
ces 500 euros pour une personne seule en
province 600 euros en ile-de-france et
700 euros à paris pour les couples ce
plafond est majoré de 60% en
contrepartie les étudiants doivent
cotiser à hauteur de 1 25 % du loyer
mensuel charges comprises avec un
plafond de 9 euros pour l'île de france
10 50 euros pour paris intra muros et
7h50 pour le reste de la france donc un
dispositif qui monte en puissance et qui
répond à un réel besoin et qui issu
d'une véritable volonté politique
merci monsieur mais nice madame gillot
voulait reprendre la parole non madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre
écoute et merci pour la précision de
votre réponse
effectivement dans le contexte actuel de
pessimisme récurrents votre réponse
porteuse d'optimisme et de volontarisme
politique ponctuent notre actualité et
marque la tenue d'engagement utile alors
que l'impatience reste vive vous avez pu
le constater donc face au temps
nécessaire pour que la sortie des
logements tant attendu arrive à leur
terme il me semble que cette mesure
graduée aussi dans la valeur du coût des
loyers qui sont garantis est tout à fait
utile et mérite d'être connue pour
donner cette garantie d'un espoir d'un
soutien à la vie étudiante réussi merci
beaucoup la parole est un monsieur alain
fouché pour le groupe ump
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en mai 2014
la ministre du logement annonce
effectivement le plan quarante mille
logements étudiants un chantier
prioritaire qui visait à mettre en
services quarante mille logements durant
tout le quinquennat dont la moitié en
ile de france afin de remédier à la
pénurie d'équipement de ce type et
améliorer les conditions de vie des
étudiants
le logement est effectivement le premier
poste dans le budget d'un étudiant il
représente 48 % de son budget au niveau
national et 55 % en ile-de-france le
manque de logements et de place dans le
parc social contraint les jeunes à
recourir au marché privé où les prix ont
connu une très forte hausse depuis dix
ans en particulier les loyers pratiqués
par les petites surfaces fréquemment
relou et les loyers à la relocation
relocation pardon ont ainsi augmenté de
50% en 10 ans un pari le plan de
l'ancien député anciaux en 2004 prévoyez
5000 logements par an lors des huit
dernières années
3000 par an ont été réalisés et 40% des
réhabilitations prévus ont été menées à
bien
le préfet prévost était chargé en 2013
une mission par la ministre du logement
et par la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur sur ce sujet pouvez vous
monsieur le ministre me donner
aujourd'hui des indications chiffrées et
précises sur l'avancement de ce plan
notamment sur le nombre de logements
déjà livrés ou en passe d'être construit
car cet objectif de 40000 de nouveaux
logements
sera-t-il tenu en temps réel merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole
madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur monsieur le sénateur fouché
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que le plan
anciaux parce que vous l'avez dit vous
avez eu cette honnêteté intellectuelle
n'a pas respecté les engagements qui
avaient été les siens loin s'en faut
donc comme notre plan 40 milles on
pourra en établir le bilan comme en 2017
et pas avant laissez moi pour l'instant
vous dire que les objectifs que nous
avons fixés sont tenus j'espère qu'il le
sera jusqu'en 2017
en tout cas 2013 et 2014 sont tenus
rappelons l'objectif 42 1916 nouvelles
places en construction neuve qui ont été
identifiés pouvant être livrée avant le
31 décembre 2017 dont trente mille
logements crous sur l'e42 1916 19 1342
sont en ile de france et il ya aussi 11
métropoles où on sait que la
particulièrement la situation est tendue
et qu'anticipent les cibler je pense à
aix marseille bordeaux créteil grenoble
lille lyon bien sûr montpellier nice
toulouse versailles et bien sûr paris
les chiffres que vous me demandez qui
sont les premiers que je peux vous
donner en matière de bilan neuf mille
500 nouvelles places ont été créées en
2013 au sein des crous dont 3900
construction et 4600 réhabilitation en
2014 bien qu'il soit encore trop tôt
pour tirer le bilan définitif 8130 place
devaient être livrés dont deux mille
deux cent quarante et une construction
et 4071 réhabilitation ces chiffres
concernent que le logement étudiant
passant par les crous il ya par ailleurs
les logements privés qui sont
aujourd'hui construit qui se rentrent
dans le plan
quarante mille parce qu'ils ont une
destination et nos cibles purement
étudiante à ce jour nous pouvons
simplement vous rappeler que cette 1600
logements étudiants ont été financés en
2013 et en 2014
on en était à l'été à 1938 sur cette
deuxième partie ce qui veut dire que les
objectifs
frais qui ont été fixés dans le plan
40000 en fin 2014 sont pour l'instant
tenus et respecté malgré certains
blocages qui peut exister sur des
chantiers privés c'est la raison pour
laquelle le premier ministre s'est
engagé à traiter ce dossier afin que ces
problèmes soient débloqués au plus vite
et c'est aussi l'idée d'une nouvelle
mission qui a été confiée à monsieur
prévost sur ce sujet merci monsieur le
ministre
alain fouché vous avez la parole à mme
la présidente monsieur le ministre le
préfet prévost jce entre parenthèses
après fait tout à fait remarquable on a
connu dans nos régions simplement merci
de ces éléments
c'est un chantier important et urgent de
nombreux propriétaires on l'a dit on ne
sait abuse et met les familles en
difficulté par des loyers surélevée par
des logements insalubres
il est donc important que ce plan va
continuer et qu'il soit réussie pour
permettre aux conti aux étudiants de
travailler dans les meilleures
conditions
merci la parole et à madame marie noëlle
lienemann
pour le groupe socialiste oui madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mais
question est un peu dans la succession
de celle de notre collègue précédent
puisque je voulais vous interroger sur
la mise en oeuvre des engagements pris
par le président de la république
concernant les 40000 places de logements
étudiants et en particulier sous forme
de résidences universitaires à caractère
social alors monsieur prévost qui n'est
pas préfet par ailleurs à ma
connaissance mais qui est haut
fonctionnaire du ministère de
l'équipement du logement est maintenant
du développement durable a effectivement
une mission vous venait d'indiquer
qu'elle allait se poursuivre et je me
permettais d'insister sur l'importance
de cette mission pourquoi parce que la
question dans ce genre de plan et
l'échec des plans précédents
en témoigne et qu'on nous annonce
beaucoup de choses au niveau central et
le suivi pour être sûr que dans chaque
territoire ce qui est annoncé programmé
ou supposés se fasse réellement n'est
pas toujours au rendez vous et le
décalage se creuse entre les annonces et
les programmations
les réalisations objective et donc je
voulais savoir mais vous l'avez déjà dit
pour une part quel est le recensement
des projets de construction réalisés et
surtout quels engagements quantitatif
ont été prises par les autorités réjane
ministre hâtive régionales est ce que la
somme des engagements régionaux
correspond à l'engagement national
si je me permets de dire ça c'est que
j'ai quelques exemples en matière de
planification de logements où on est
censé avoir un plan national on fait le
total de ce que prévu dans la région
c'est inférieur à ce que des prévu au
niveau national toujours être sûr que
dans ce domaine ce tales ne soit pas le
cas comment on peut apprécier
l'avancement concrètes ces projets et
l'engagement sur les trois premières
années
deuxièmement il ya des simplifications
administratives on a vu ça hier qu'ils
étaient envisagées pour alléger les
procédures et les coûts de ces
constructions
alors il y avait plusieurs domaines
stationnement la l'accessibilité aux
handicapés le l'occupation temporaire du
domaine d'état les la maîtrise d ouvrage
et c est ce que ces mesures de
simplification sont engagés avez vous un
calendrier sur leur mise en oeuvre et
enfin la loi lure prévoyait la
définissant la définition de résidences
universitaires à caractère social
est ce que les textes d'application sont
engagés et en particulier pour que ses
débuts définition s'applique pour le
conventionnement de l'apl chalet régis
un collègue
seul le poids du logement dans les
dépenses des étudiants est essentielle
pour leur pouvoir d'achat leurs
conditions d'études
monsieur le ministre la présidente
madame et messieurs les sénateurs madame
la ministre je ne tenais pas moi qui ai
dit que le monsieur prévost avait pris
le statut de préfet en plus il me semble
de mémoire que c'est quelqu'un que vous
appréciez beaucoup et qui a collaboré à
vos côtés et qui a toute valeur pour
mener à bien les missions qu'on lui
confie il ya plusieurs questions dans
votre question je vais essayer d'être le
plus exhaustif possible comme ça dans la
programmation
pardonnez moi si je livre les chiffres
comme ça mais tout est bien calculé
on avait six mille 21 logements en 2013
2 prévu 5380 2014 9263 2015 9046 2016
es13 1206 2017 pour atteindre les 42
1916 que j'ai cité en ce qui concerne
les mesures que vous attendiez le
ministère du logement et même pinel
travaille actuellement aux précisions
réglementaires qui sont relatives au
nouveau statut
ce statut qui dépendent de la loi à
l'urée et permet de répondre aux
difficultés qui sont liés aux résidences
étudiantes financer en pls et en paix
les us à des logements familiaux
ordinaire c'est ce que vous nous disiez
notamment concernant les modalités
d'attribution la durée d'occupation et
de récupération des charges locatives
à cet égard donc il convient d'adapter
la convention applicable à ces logements
aujourd'hui couverts par la convention
applicable aux âges aux hlm de droit
commun qui sont qui est peu adapté à
leurs spécificités
par exemple le régime juridique de ces
nouvelles résidences universitaires
introduit par la loi allure et
dérogatoire du droit commun du
conventionnement notamment s'agissant de
la durée des baux dont la durée maximale
me semble-t-il de mémoire et de un an et
de l'absence de droit au maintien dans
les lieux
il ya donc un décret à cet effet qui
sera pris très prochainement dès lors et
jusqu'à ce qu'un décret interviennent
les conventions signées avec les crous
peuvent et doivent être utilisés en
l'état en matière de simplification
vous avez rappelé déjà là le décret du
16 mars 2014
concernant les normes d'accessibilité
l'ordonance du 3 octobre 2013
concernant les stationnements et le
travail se poursuit dans le cas de la
mise en oeuvre du plan 40 milles pour
lever les blocages qui peuvent exister
pour la réalisation de certaines
opérations de logements qui sont bloqués
jouer a dit monsieur le premier ministre
en liaison avec mon collègue thierry
mandon travaillent sur ces questions
merci monsieur le ministre marie noëlle
lienemann
oui bah écoutez je veux féliciter le
gouvernement de sa volonté de marcher à
rythme soutenu pour l'application de ses
engagements en souhaitant qu'au niveau
local les questions qu'a posées monsieur
lézard sur les compétences des uns et
des autres ne paralyse pas à terme la
mise en oeuvre des objectifs
merci beaucoup la parole est à madame
colette mélot pour le groupe ump
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
se plaçant après 8
autre question je ne peux qu insisté sur
la nécessité de construire des logements
étudiants
en effet il est de plus en plus
difficile pour les étudiants d'accéder à
un logement privé en raison du nombre
insuffisant de location dans les villes
et de l'augmentation des loyers
je précise que les loyers des petites
surfaces ont augmenté de 3,1 pour cent à
paris et 2 2 % en province avec une
envolée des charges locatives de 10 à
14% selon le type de logement la
solution pour bon nombre d'étudiants et
de trouver un logement social dans les
résidences universitaires du crous
mais elle reste en nombre insuffisant
ainsi on compte actuellement 170 mille
étudiants habitant dans ses résidences
tandis que plus d'un million d'étudiants
sont locataires dans le parc privé
le président de la république s'est
engagé sur un objectif précis de
construction de 43 mille logements d'ici
fin 2010 est cet engagement est
important puisqu'il représente près de
25 % du parc immobilier gérées par les
crous
alors que le gouvernement peine à
trouver des sources de financement cette
période de restrictions budgétaires
pourriez vous nous préciser monsieur le
ministre comment vous trouverez les
fonds nécessaires et quelle méthode vous
emploierez pour déterminer les villes
prioritaires
je voudrais également avoir votre
opinion sur une demande récurrente des
élus locaux devoir intégrer l'ensemble
des logements étudiants dans la part de
logements sociaux imposé aux communes
par la loi sru du 13 décembre 2000
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre je
vous en prie vous avez la parole oui
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs concernant la
façon dont on finance le logement
étudiant il se planque 40000 le logement
étudiant produit par les filières
sociale ce mode de financement le plus
quand vous le savez le pls l'utilisation
pour les logements étudiants du ps a été
ouvert par la circulaire de 2003
pérenniser en 2005 il ne permet pas
d'obtenir des aides à la pierre mais
l'agrément permet une ouverture de
droits à l'application d'un taux de tva
réduit à l'exonération de la taxe
foncière et au conventionnement à l'aide
personnalisée au logement
c'est donc comme cela le cas pour
l'ensemble des logements locatifs
sociaux dans certaines zones tendues un
accord peut être obtenu pour réaliser
des opérations en paix les u16 quelques
chiffres pour vous compreniez 7700
logements étudiants ont été financés en
cela fait un coût moyen de 70000 euros
par logement les aides publiques moyenne
par logement s'évalue à l'heure en pls à
40000 euros par logement dans un peu
plus de la moitié viennent de l'état aux
aides au titre des aides fiscales pour
le logement étudiant privé il s'agit
d'un investissement locatif où nous
n'avons malheureusement que très peu de
chiffres
en ce qui concerne les réhabilitations
dont vous parliez des fameuses résidence
étudiante en termes de réhabilitation le
rapport anciaux avait préconisé la
requalification de l'offre obsolète afin
de répondre aux besoins des étudiants
défavorisés financièrement on estime à
70 milles places
en dix ans les besoins de réhabilitation
la modernisation du parc ancien du crous
et donc financé par un supplément
d'allocations de logement à caractère
social de 50 euros par logement et par
mois cela fait cinquante cinq mille
places pour les étudiants qui ont été
réhabilités entre 2004 et 2013 et je
vous ai dit dans le plan
40000 comment nous allions accélérer
encore ce nombre de réhabilitation
nécessaires pour répondre à un vrai
besoin que vous avez juste très
justement souligné
un vrai besoin croissant de logements
étudiants à bas prix pour les étudiants
qui veulent étudier notamment dans la
région parisienne
merci monsieur ministre madame mélo oui
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie pour toutes
ces précisions nous pourrons constater
si ces ces projets sont vraiment
respectée mais vous ne m'avez pas
répondu à la question concernant le la
part de logements imposé aux communes
par la loi sru et sur la question de
pouvoir intégrer les logements étudiants
dans l'appart dans le quota de logements
sociaux
je vous remercie de bien vouloir donner
suite à cette à cette question merci
madame je vais suspendre la séance merci
monsieur le ministre
elle sera reprise
à 16 heures pour la suite de la
discussion voilà pour ces questions
cribles consacré au logement étudiant
à noter dès les premières minutes de la
séance vous avez pu entendre certains
sénateurs qui ont regretté que ce soit
le secrétaire d'état aux sports thierry
braillard qui soit venu leur répondre
sur ce dossier dans l'hémicycle et non
l'un des ministres en charge de ce
dossier comme silvia pinal ministre du
logement ou encore la secrétaire d'état
à l'enseignement supérieur
sinon vous l'avez constaté bien de
nombreux sénateurs se sont inquiétés du
manque de logements étudiants notamment
et bien la sénatrice communiste
catherine morin de brigitte gonthier
maurin qui a parlé du cas particulier de
la résidence universitaire d'antony en
région parisienne mais aussi du
centriste claude kern qui a rappelé que
dans la seule région parisienne et bien
seulement 3 % des étudiants parviennent
à avoir une place en résidence
universitaire rappelons qu'actuellement
un plan 40000 est lancé 40000 nouvelle
construction de chambres en résidences
universitaires d'ailleurs de très
nombreux sénateurs se sont inquiétés de
savoir où on était l'élaboration de ce
plan s'il allait parvenir à être
réalisés autre problème qui a été
souligné par le sénateur écologiste joël
labbé bien le montant des loyers dans le
parc privé
je le cite il faut étudier pour éviter
le chômage travailler pour pouvoir
étudier
il a d'ailleurs regretté que le système
d'encadrement des loyers qui était prévu
dans la loi allures de cécile duflot
soit finalement restreint à des
expérimentations à paris et à lille
enfin notons que la réforme territoriale
s'est invitée dans ces questions cribles
sur le logement étudiant avec
l'intervention de jacques mézard le
président du groupe rdse ici au sénat
seront pas majorité de radicaux de
gauche
non sans ironie il a demandé comment les
nouvelles grandes régions stratège
allait se saisir de ce problème
rappelons que les radicaux de gauche
sont de très fervents adversaires de
cette réforme à partir de 16h30
et bien ne manquez pas la suite des
rencontres de l'association des
départements de france avec la réforme
territoriale toujours
un débat sur la réforme territoriale à
18 heures hé bien ça sera l'audition de
jean-pierre raffarin au sénat l'ancien
premier ministre auditionnée sur la
réforme territoriale
acte 2 et à 16h et bien vous allez
pouvoir voir notre documentaire la
reconquête du sénat duel au plateau de
notre rédaction
très bonne fin de journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires